[Music]
after 9/11 everyone was scared scared it
might happen again it was my second day
of grad school next day I changed all my
classes to national security morning and
morning sooner have you seen the story
today in the New York Times evidently
the CIA destroyed tapes of
interrogations of al-qaeda detainees I
want to find out what was on the tapes
why they were destroyed no paper papers
were getting people in trouble men our
place at our place papers how we keep
track of laws last night I found this
he's detainee number 24 you guys see
this no no watch the video they
waterboarded him a hundred and eighty
three times everything they got from him
was either a lie or something they
already had if it works why do you need
to do it 183 times maybe one a report
comes out people will finally see that
I've you mentally disagree with the
narrative here the United States does
not torture Dan you need to be careful
here they can't destroy the documents
they can go after the next best thing
yeah they claimed they saved lives but
what they really did was make it
impossible to prosecute a mass murderer
because if what we did to him ever came
out in a court of law the case is over
the guy planned 9/11 we will not allow
this to be covered antennas to gain
Intel save American long histories
written by the victors you need to
change our how does that even happen
nothing could be further from the
democracy is messy if The Times had your
report we would print it tomorrow no if
it's gonna come out it's gonna come out
the right way
you